it's always risky isn't it to read too
much into polls however some of the
polls out this morning are pretty
extraordinary if the comrades worn in
the Sunday Telegraph for example not
only shows the brexit party beating the
Conservatives in the European elections
but also a general election and you
would be on course for your worst ever
results I mean what's your reaction to
that well I think we're living through
some pretty extraordinary times this
European election which frankly nobody
wanted or nobody expected is going to be
in my view a giant opinion poll as to
the merits of brexit whilst I don't
think mainstream politicians can ignore
or disregard the frustration of the
electorate and it's very clear that
there is a great degree of frustration
the question is what are we going to do
about it
what are you gonna do well it's for
Parliament I think to get its act
together and actually govern in a way
that would honor the manifesto
commitment not just to the Conservative
Party but of the Labour Party as well
see nearly 600 MPs were elected on a
brexit manifesto this is where this is
where I struggled though because
listening to you there you're just
saying that how you can all respond to
these absolutely appalling polls of the
Conservative Party and its effective
view just by doing the same thing we're
trying to get withdrawal deal through we
don't need to change something well
that's what's happening at the moment
with the talks between the government
and the opposition I very much hope that
something will emerge from that I think
it's incumbent upon MPs of all shades to
realise that what we're dealing with
here is a tension between the direct
democracy of the referendum that most
MPs voted for and parliamentary
democracy itself we need to resolve that
tension quickly and we need to remember
that it is Parliament that is in the
dock here and we need to respond in a
responsible way and deliver not only
brexit but also a sense of trust and
faith in democracy and parliamentary
democracy itself it's not just
Parliament though it's in government in
the dock as well oh you fail to get it
through and if you you know look at the
poll today I mean you could be on course
to lose your seat your majorities only
compa thousand well look I've always had
a marginal seat Sophie and I work very
hard in my constituency knowing that
I'll be there at the wish of the
electorate who I am proud to represent
that's been a reality of my life I've
never been complacent about my
politics and I'm certainly not
complacent now which is why I've been
working extremely hard as Solicitor
General to help get the deal through and
I'm going to continue doing my part as
justice minister is it time for the
prime minister to send out a timetable
for her resignation well Prime Minister
said that she's going to go once the
first phase or brexit has been delivered
that must mean the ratification process
that withdrawal agreement bill and all
the parliamentary procedures that need
to happen in order for phase one to be
completed now if that can be done
quickly then we have that timetable set
out already
I don't think she needs to say any more
about that what we need to do is get on
with the job come together and get a
solution for the British people the
problem is that we don't know when that
is going to happen to it we don't know
when the first phase is going to be
delivered or even if it will be
delivered and at the same time we have a
government that appears to be in
paralysis I mean as them in a vote in
the House of Commons chamber for a month
how long can it go on for well of course
don't confuse votes in the Commons with
government action there's plenty of work
going on in my department and in health
and in other departments of state that
is making a big change to people's lives
the economy is in a good position the
deficit is being balanced a lot of
important work going on I accept the
brexit of course drones all that out and
like everybody else in the country I
want to move on I want to see an end to
this and I think it can be done
in this spring and summer if Parliament
actually comes together and steps up to
the plate and delivers we're talking
about moving on it feels to me as if the
conservative is it's got a bit of an
existential problem going forward you
have to decide what kind of party you
want to be what what kind of people you
want to appeal to I mean what kind of
politician do you think the next leader
of the Conservative Party should be well
look I'm looking for a leader who will
embody the values of one nation
conservatism that is a true reach out
not just to some mythical center ground
but to the common ground of politics in
our country the values of our country
which are open-minded generous believing
in the rule of law are all these issues
I think that we need to emphasize
Britain's role in the world is still an
important one and I'm looking for a
conservative leader who can employ
do that and reflect 21st century Britain
as it is now with ersity
I'm not going to get in so then so forth
attract I can issue that I'm not going
to be one of them it's become a bit of a
grand national field and I don't think
it needs any more crowding okay there
you go
and now you've only been in your job a
couple days and but I do want to are
some broad questions about your brief as
well David Gork the Justice Secretary
has talked a lot about short sentences
not being effective so do you think that
we lock too many people up I think the
problem is having sat as a part-time
judge myself and made those decisions
about sending people to prison or not I
can tell you that what we need is a very
clear set of choices so that judges can
have confidence that a community a
sentence will actually work in stopping
that person from reoffending and do you
think now they don't do you think that
they can be seen as a soft option well
it's not so much that its effectiveness
and how they work I think there are far
that the reoffending rates are too high
short term sentences so I think about a
70% reoffending rate now that's not just
inefficient it's bad for society it
means there are more victims of crime
out there I think we've got to redouble
our efforts to actually not just look at
sentencing itself but improve the
options in the community to make them
more rigorous so make sure to work
harder to make sure that those
reoffending rates can be reduced that's
the challenge which which I'm up for I'm
was keen to ask you as well about a
story that's been in the news quite a
lot recently about rape victims and
potentially have been asked to give over
their mobile phones you know to police
or else their you know their case may
not go forward do you think that's
acceptable well I've been working as
Solicitor General on the very issue of
disclosure and I'm very clear that there
needs to be a balance between the need
for a proper examination of the material
in the case but avoiding this sort of
tick box exercise where people's private
lives and irrelevant issues are being
looked at the law is very clear
reasonable lines of inquiry should be
followed and ill and asking the
reasonable well it can be it can be
there might be material in some cases
that is relevant but I think victims and
complainants should be reassured that
the law is clear it's not about a trolls
to everybody's private lives and sure
they know that's the problem there's
there's great cases in particular people
are very worried about completely
irrelevant things about your sexual
history or previous partners being
brought to cool
yeah well quite rude of law are very
clear about that unless there's a
specific issue in the case then a
barristers are not allowed to just go
willy nilly into people's private lives
I think striking the balance is the
important message we've got to send out
there and you know as a minister I can
say to victims and complainants out
there the law is there to protect you to
protect them and getting that balance
between the need to look at relevant
evidence but not this you know massive
one-size-fits-all trawl through private
lives is vitally important for police
officers and for prosecutors to a deity
okay and then just finally and your
predecessor will restore it made a
pledge didn't he promise that got quite
a lot of media attention he said last
summer that he would resign if he
couldn't bring down violence and drug
use in ten prisons within a year so are
you gonna resign it does it pass on
through to you well look I'm gonna do it
my way I pay tribute to Rory Stewart he
was an energetic and passionate prisons
minister I bring nearly 30 years of
experience in the penal and criminal
justice system to bear into that my new
role I'm going to do it in my way I can
be held accountable for prisons and
probation and I know where will in
Parliament and in the media but I'm
going to carry on the hard work that he
started I'm going to redouble the
efforts not just in those prisons but
also in the over a hundred prisons that
we have in our system and to help our
hard-working prison staff and prison
service in reducing violence and also
reducing drug use in our prisons as well
so if you're doing it your way just very
quickly what are you going to do
differently well I'm going to focus on
the whole system because as I was saying
to you earlier Sophie I'm particularly
interested in the interplay between
prison and probation and those first 24
hours after a prisoner is released are
vital hours that should not be lost it's
often things a drop things are not done
which can lead to reoffending at a very
early stage we've got to get that
through the prison gate
process absolutely right okay Robert
Buckland thanks very much for being on
the program today